Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for the 112th episode and one year!
One year since the very beginning of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Right!
Our anniversary episode!
Can you believe it?
We've got 112 episodes in one year.
One year.
BAU BAU!
I can't believe it, Ruffians!
But thank you so much for joining us!
Waking up maybe some early some mornings.
Right!
Maybe kind of not quite making it out of bed on some.
But thank you for just allowing us to see you.
We're singing in the morning and allowing us to protect your smile too.
For a whole year.
BAU BAU!
Well, for Ruffians who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag.
FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's time to BAU BAU, Ruffians!
Has it been started on the right paw?
Well, it's gonna be a super exciting and fun day today, Ruffians!
So... Get ready!
BAU BAU!
Well, uh... Speaking of starting it out on the right paw... I think there's been another Pero Sighting.
What, what, what, what?
I thought we were gonna start this off on the right paw, Moco-chan.
No, Pero Sighting.
Let's wear... Let's wear Pero!
No!
Let's see where he went.
Or went so on.
Okay.
On.
De-den, Moco-chan.
De-den!
On!
Hello, Moco-chan.
De-den!
Maybe try once more, Moco-chan.
Huh?
W-w-where's Pero?
Goodwillins.
Huh?
Goodwillins!
Ruffians!
I don't know.
You know, it has been a year now since we debuted, right?
Could it be that maybe Pero finally decided to not show up anymore?
Right?
Right, yeah.
He hasn't really been showing his face around here at all for a while, you know?
You've been seeing him, but... Us?
Right.
You know?
Well...
It's a miracle!
Behind you... You say that all the time!
He's not behind us!
Nobody's behind us!
Nobody's behind us, okay?
Yeah... Right?
Maybe, you know... This could be it?
Maybe he went back to the Northwest Passage and... It's just... Just going into a quiet environment.
Retired like a father, too.
But he's gone now.
Now he's retired at the very least.
He's gone.
Yeah...
I don't know.
It was a good one!
Yeah, Peron!
Yeah!
Right!
Wait, Ruffians!
You're not sad, right?
Right?
Justice captured him!
Oh, he's stronger than that.
Okay.
Moco-chan.
Ruffians look a little bit sad.
Oh.
I don't like it when the Ruffians are sad though.
It's been a year, you know.
A year.
Pero's an old dog and that's why he's so nasty.
So, you have to save him!
You're crying for Pero!
The tears are a waste!
It's okay, Ruffians.
It's his time.
BAU BAU!
He's having fun.
He's retired somewhere.
BAU BAU!
Great paw stuff.
Yeah!
Today it's our first anniversary, the one year of FUWAMOCO Morning.
And you know, something that we also shared with you Ruffians,
One year ago, there's been some really good news!
Our cover of Kaibutsu has hit 5 million views on YouTube!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for this!
5 million!
It means so much to us, Ruffians!
We put so much of ourselves into singing kaibutsu.
We really wanted to be FUWAMOCO.
And we wanted to share, you know, just how fluffy and fuzzy and how hungry we are together with you, Ruffians.
So, thank you so much for listening to more tonight!
FUWAMOCO, we're gonna continue to do our best to make things, you know, the FUWAMOCO way.
Make it ours.
And hopefully, in our second year, we can release lots more music too.
More songs, more covers.
Especially if you continue to support us.
Lots and lots of love for music.
Please take a listen if you haven't, okay?
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Speaking of music, we talked about it last week.
Other day.
The other day, Advent's new original song, Sirens, was just released.
Ruffians, you've had to listen to it, right?
Maybe a couple times now.
Because we couldn't talk to you.
There's a little bit of a secret part in it.
Did you figure it out?
Yeah.
It's a whole big part, Ruffians.
Yeah, the secret part.
The funny part.
The goofy part.
What is the goofy part?
I'm so surprised the Ruffians didn't notice yet.
I haven't seen it yet.
The Moon After Lightning!
What are you talking about?
Are you making things up?
Hit me, I'll hit back.
Huh?
That's how the song goes.
Hit me, I'll hit back.
BAU BAU BAU.
Just like that.
Yeah, the topped up vocals.
Nope, that's just normal.
Secret Pero Pero's not singing in it.
That is not a part of Advent!
No!
Yeah.
Oh yeah, Moco-chan.
Is that what FUWAMO makes it this time?
No?
It's right in your face.
You didn't notice.
Ruffians!
You know the part where Biboo and Shiori are singing?
You know the... Turn it up a notch, make it dangerous.
Drifting through the night, we're outrageous.
Cursing through our veins, you can't tame us.
Turn it up a notch, make it dangerous.
Did you realize?
Sticking out your jaw for no reason.
You're so BAU BAU.
You're so bibutak.
I just wanna be your Shiori.
It's true!
It's true, Ruffians!
Yeah!
Oh no!
Now you'll never ever be able to un-cute Ruffians!
Yeah!
Actually, we didn't realize until people sang it for us.
Yeah, we were like... Huh?
Huh?
It was already done and everything.
We got you Ruffians!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
That's funny.
That just means you have to listen to it again.
Then you'll hear it.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO You didn't hear it?
FUWAMOCO Yeah, Advent, I'll try unhearing you.
FUWAMOCO Right!
Right!
FUWAMOCO Can't escape.
FUWAMOCO You cannot escape.
FUWAMOCO BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO I can't believe it took you so long, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO We just had to sing it once, we didn't even do anything.
FUWAMOCO We just sung it how it is!
FUWAMOCO Yeah!
FUWAMOCO Wow.
Ruffians don't have very good ears, huh?
We have big ears.
We didn't know this for a while either.
BAU BAU!
You've been bibotaged.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Definitely go listen, okay?
Yeah.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Do you like those kind of things?
I like the lyrics.
I like those kind of things.
But...
It's so ruin!
Ruin in the best way possible!
BAU BAU!
You know, it's something special that we share all together no matter what you say, Ruffians!
Everyone, enough speaking of Biboo tags!
Yesterday, it was Biboo's anniversary!
And so she had a really fun stream!
All together with a bunch of my senpai!
Singing!
And, FUWAMOCO, we will be singing too, but not just us and Biboo, but with my senpai!
All together!
We're so happy to be able to sing with Biboo, but then Biboo will be like,
Why don't we sing this all together?
All four of us!
So together we sung I'm Your Treasure Box by FUWAMOCO!
Yeah, Biboo had a very good reason for this, right?
Yeah.
She did.
Why is that Moco-chan?
To try to become more sexy.
That Moco-chan included too, right?
Maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe not.
Right.
And hopefully she did, but I don't know.
I was just feeling like, aw, Biboo's so cute.
Aw, she's trying.
But she's cute!
I liked it!
It was so fun!
I feel like another dream of ours came true.
Right!
As you know, that Mondo.
White one.
Which one?
There's nothing of the sort.
Nothing of the sort.
And you know what?
That one.
FUWAMOCO, we got to hear Mari-senchou-senpai's beautiful voice right directly into our soul too.
Of course Biboo's voice too, but we hear that kind of often too.
And I love it.
It was so much fun!
Yeah.
Please take it if you haven't or can't!
Yeah, and hopefully, you know, one day, well, we're gonna sing with Biboo.
The three of us.
Absolutely, that's gonna happen, but it'd be nice if one day we can sing together with Morning Senpai.
Good job everyone!
Bye bye!
Yeah, it was so much fun, but congratulations, Biboo, on your first anniversary!
And of course, Shiori!
And Nerissa, too!
BAU BAU!
Everything just flows perfectly into each other, but on the topic of Morning Sensation, but yesterday...
Yesterday yesterday, two yesterdays ago, it was her birthday!
And she released a brand new song!
Have you listened?
It's amazing!
Dead Mama's Chest.
It's so cool, the MV, right?
It's crazy!
But the song is so good too!
Yeah, this song is made together with Chameleon and Toby Fox.
Yeah!
It sounds just like, you know, like a boss battle theme.
I don't know, we both really love Mighty Buckle.
I don't think you can just say the animation was really good, okay?
No, the song's really good too!
But I think the animation goes past just...
It was really good.
This is, you know, the theatrical version.
A theatrical release.
Before that?
Beyond that?
No, it's beyond.
Beyond that.
My favorite scenes, there's so many favorite scenes, like you just don't know what's gonna happen next, but you, they have the dragon, right, and all the scales and everything.
I just, I like the smaller scenes.
The amazing ones are amazing, but I think everything is nice.
Like here we have Senchou-senpai with those glowing eyes, that expression, that part was... But it's sort of an answer song to Mighty Buckle, right?
Maybe let's just Moco-chan your mind.
I don't think so.
They kind of do connect, you know?
They connect.
They're parts, too.
They 100% connect.
Yeah.
And then, you know, the rose scene where the rose is like, wow.
It reminded me a bit of Utena as well.
She said it herself.
Got you.
Yes!
But, you know, I really want to go back and like, I don't want to!
Watch it, watch it.
You know, there's a lot of thought.
A lot of love that's gone into it.
Amazing amount.
I need to go deep into it.
Happy birthday, Senchou-senpai!
FUWAMOCO!
And not just that too, Marine-senchou-senpai is releasing an album!
Right!
There's so much exciting things.
Yeah.
But...
Exciting thing!
It's our story!
Our anniversary!
We told you, but... But it took more than you know.
You know now, we spent a full year together with you, Ruffians.
And now today, it's officially the start of our second year in hololive.
Do you understand what that means, Ruffians?
No!
We're in the middle of our second year.
Not the middle, we just started.
That's the middle.
Can you believe that?
I can't believe it's already been a year.
I don't understand anything.
Sometimes I feel that way too.
Yeah!
But!
But, you know, it's our first anniversary.
Today is the day.
So we're gonna be having a big celebration!
But you know, yesterday we had a bit of a countdown.
So we could spend the exact moment with you!
Yeah, say goodbye to our first year.
Hello to the second year together!
But!
We had a bit of a... Something special.
Right!
Huh?
You might have found out what the little mysterious thing on our schedule was.
Tomorrow, or tomorrow, today!
Today!
At 8.30pm P.T.
FUWAMOCO!
We're releasing our first original song!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Just a few hours from now, Ruffians!
It'll be shared with you very soon, so please join us for a celebration!
We have a bunch of exciting things too, right?
You know, of course we're gonna do the FUWAMOCO things, whatever those are.
The real stuff.
You know, some surprises as well.
But, you know...
We also have some special FUWAMOCO stuff coming out!
That you'll definitely, definitely, definitely want to be there for.
I'm so excited.
Special merchandise.
Good!
You know, our birthday, there's a bunch of exciting things.
Yeah!
For weeks, you know, we had the Ruffian plushies and everything.
But this time... I wonder what we have, huh?
I know, and limited signatures too.
Right.
But this time, a little bit different.
Huh?
But we worked really hard trying to get the best, best, best merchandise!
That'll make you lotsa happy.
We hope that you'll look forward to the big surprise too!
BAU BAU!
It starts at 10 AM TST!
6 PM PST!
So we hope that you'll be able to be
Then, to say... HAPPY BIRTHDAY NUMBER THREE!
To all FUWAMOCO Ruffians!
Oh, you'll never miss it!
BAU BAU!
You can make it!
We're gonna do our best.
It's a special birthday number three.
BAU BAU!
New adventures together too, so... BAU BAU!
But, you know, there's a lot of exciting things going on, but you know, maybe there's some rough things to have light.
You know, it's Wednesday.
You just want it to be a weekend at this point, right?
But, what about Wednesday?
At least, at the very least, you know there's a party that you can go to after everything.
After the day, after you know you're like, I'm done with this.
Right.
What?
Pup Talk.
Hai!
Moco-chan, do you have something to make the day a little bit more... Buzzy.
Puzzy.
You want fuzzy?
We want fuzzy!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
You know what time it is.
It hasn't been a full year of them yet, but uh... It's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear straight from me, Mococo!
Uh, so uh... Somehow, we've got here!
An actual, whole, crazy, amazing year as members of hololive!
You know, uh, throughout a year, we've accomplished a lot!
I mean, lots of amazing memories!
But...
I think for most demon dogs out there, the idea of all the pressure and that sort of thing could be sort of overwhelming.
But the most important thing is actually just taking everything just a step at a time.
We have no clue what we're doing.
No clue!
But we're just going forward and doing our best.
You know, a step every day gets you somewhere eventually.
You don't need to rush.
Although,
We do tend to rush ourselves, but that's just because we're hungry, you know?
Normal, huh?
Anyways, just remember that you can't rush your journey, and that slowly growing and gaining experience is so important!
You can't know everything all at once, okay?
You need to set realistic expectations for yourself and what you can do.
You know, otherwise you'll just disappoint yourself needlessly when you're actually doing an amazing job, okay?
So, don't disregard your hard work and accomplishments.
It's good to do your best, but make sure to rest too, okay?
Let's keep on doing our best into the second year together, okay?
We can do it!
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Abyss, that's the pup talk.
How about that?
BAU BAU!
Well, let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
BAU BAU!
It's... It's Amber!
That's some silly eyes.
Right!
Big eyes!
BAU BAU!
Abyss here really likes swimming.
And actually was trying to influence her little sister to go to the water too.
But Blondie... Blondie just wanted to chase the leaves.
They can be interesting, but... Panda dog!
BAU BAU!
Sorry, Bonnie.
You know, I guess it's your older sister's day to be the Doggie of the Day today.
Congrats, Amber!
BAU BAU!
Panda in disguise!
Right?
The dog is smiling, right?
Because Amber is super cute.
Moco-chan, how does Amber BAU BAU?
BAU BAU.
Oh, BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
How does Amber BAU BAU?
Moco-chan!
Are you troubled right now?
I'm troubled.
How does Amber BAU BAU?
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
You heard her, Ruffians!
That's how Amber BAU BAUs!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, a little smirk there.
Right?
So cute!
You know, Amber, Amber, she's always trying to share the way to be the best doggie possible with her little sister.
But, I think it's maybe proving to be an uphill battle.
I understand that feeling, Amber.
Yeah.
We're really similar.
But if you keep on doing your best, you'll be the Doggie of the Day every day for your Ruffians!
Do your best, okay?
BAU BAU!
I love Amber's beautiful brown eyes too.
So cute!
Panda.
Shiori.
Nope.
Doggie of the Day.
Amber.
BAU BAU.
And for today I went on a walk!
We have De-den!
It's all the same but from different seasons.
That's so special!
You know, especially sharing it with us after the first year we spent together has ended.
All the seasons.
It really paints an amazing picture of all the seasons we've spent together.
And you know, it also just shows how many walks you've been on too!
That too, you know.
Showing the truth.
The truth!
Hi!
BAU BAU!
You're very sweet, huh?
Thank you!
It means a lot.
BAU BAU!
And next for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
You've been protecting our smiles for a year now.
I would like to think so.
Looking back on what you've done to protect our smiles so far, do you think you've done a good job?
And do you still think you can do it even better?
Better job of protecting our smiles!
Better job!
I think we have!
I would like to think so, huh?
We did our absolute best, you know, and we learned a lot of things this year.
Became even stronger teaming goals.
I think, you know, we're going to use all the experience and knowledge we gained to protect your smile even more during our second year.
You know, I guess sometimes though,
There will be things where we might disappoint you.
Times, you know.
It's just how it is.
But if we do one thing you know that makes you happy, it might equally make someone else unhappy.
And we can't know.
All we can do is do what we think is best.
You know, we're gonna do it!
The FUWAMOCO way!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, and hopefully I'll protect your smile forever and ever, too.
Thank you!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, thank you so much for being a part, being here with us for FUWAMOCO Morning for now a full, full year!
Thank you!
We're always waiting for you to be an even bigger part of FUWAMOCO Morning!
So, you know, if you have a question, if you went on a walk and saw something kind of interesting, you know, maybe you saw Pero around, although I think he's in retirement, you know, if
That's a doggy of a day.
A doggy in your life.
Please let us know with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream.
Wow, we did talk about it.
But, we have de-den!
FUWAMOCO's first anniversary celebration!
It's a big one, huh?
Which, uh...
We won't say because we already said it once and if the wolfies are kind of sleepy then that's... It's an original song.
BAU BAU!
But we still have more surprises!
More surprises!
More fun stuff!
So we really hope that you'll be there so that we can share it together with you and make even more special memories too!
BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians, let's take another look at our schedule.
On Thursday, on the 1st, we have an after party.
You're forgetting after the celebration.
After the celebration, you know we have an original song.
And then we have a chatting, you know, this way it's gonna be easier all together.
And on the Thursday, we have an after party.
That's very important.
Maybe we're gonna do a lot of it.
A lot of chatting about, well, our original song that's very very special to us.
And maybe some things you would like to know a lot, yeah?
Right.
Especially that, right?
Yeah.
Hopefully you'll join us for that.
And then, on the second, we have Shiori's 3D debut!
And on the third, Biboo's 3D debut!
It's so soon!
Our anniversary week, oh my gosh.
Crazy.
Fogs.
Fogs, of course.
Of course, Ruffians.
Yeah, fogs.
Who cares about a 3D debut?
Fogs, huh?
You know, Fogs... It was special, you know.
Fogs is special.
It has a lot of memories, a lot of angry memories, too.
Switch was in danger, huh?
Yeah.
But, you know... Maybe it's a good thing that we didn't complete it because now we can play all together a year later, too.
It's not like Fogs has a story, either.
No.
BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians who are joining us through the archives today, here is your FUWAMOCO award!
It's BAU BAU BAUNUMESURY!
BAU BAU!
Happy BAUNUMESURY!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for-
Our second years.
Your second year hololive's first FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Star Summer.
BAU BAU!
Ice Cold.
Chuu Udon.
BAU BAU!
Kan Mikan.
Hoppy.
BAU BAU!
Kamomiru.
Pierre.
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!